Speaker 1: All right.
We have to review CPAC, the Conservative Political
Action Conference hosted by the American Conservative
Union.
Did you know?
I feel like they just did CPAC in Florida.
They did it again in Texas this weekend.
We are going to go through speeches, we are
going to go through attendee's, we are going
to look at the results of the straw poll.
It's just a big CPAC day.
We're getting all the CPAC stuff out of the
way.
The first thing we're going to start with
is Donald Trump's speech that he gave at CPAC.
The big theme of the speech was Trump telling
lies about the election and also lots of really
weird and incoherent things happening.
So let's just start going through it.
We'll start with some of the weird stuff in
this first clip.
Trump's teeth sort of chirp.
It's an unusual thing.
And he launches an attack, of course, on wind
farms, his favorite enemy.
Speaker 3: And we don't need windmills in
Texas and lots of other places, we don't need
one in that program as quickly as they can.
Speaker 1: So Trump, they're continuing his
brutal assault on wind power, a completely
incoherent one.
And yeah.
Teeth chirping.
Very interestingly, Trump then continuing
to sort of struggle to get certain words out
here, talking about illegal youth arrives
and arrivals send border patrol.
Speaker 3: Overall, illegal youth arrives
and arrivals are up nearly five.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So not only are youth arrivals up, but youth
arrives, are also up.
And then Trump really getting into, I guess,
what we would sort of call the meat of the
speech, which is starting to talk about how
we actually won.
And someone yells, Trump won.
And the crowd just absolutely loves this.
Speaker 3: We all want, we all
Speaker 1: want, yeah, we all won.
Yeah, we did, really.
And then it starts to get more confusing.
And this next clip, Trump lists things that
worked against him during the election, but
he's still sort of one.
But it was like they cheated.
But he won anyway, even though not really
publicly announced it.
I mean, see if you can follow this
Speaker 3: then without any basis whatsoever.
Twitter and Facebook banned the New York Post
account of this terrible story right after
the election.
One poll showed that at least 10 percent of
Joe Biden's voters would have switched their
vote if they had known about Joe and Hunter
Biden scandals.
Speaker 1: So this is the idea that the the
Hunter Biden, quote, scandal about bringing
three laptops across the country to a blind
guy who's not sure, but thinks because of
a sticker that they were probably Hunter's
hard drives.
You know, if that hadn't been suppressed by
the so-called fake news media, Trump would
have done
Speaker 3: enough to flip the results of numerous
states.
Speaker 1: But he won anyway.
Right.
So he would have won, but he won anyway.
Speaker 3: But don't worry about it because
we won those states anyway.
Speaker 1: Wait a second.
So did did that make it so you lost or did
you actually win?
It's all very, very confusing.
And then Trump continued pushing this.
And as Trump likes to say, if you repeat a
lie often enough, people start to see it as
the truth.
And he continued doing the vote rigging stuff.
Speaker 3: Every time the media references
the election hoax, they say the fraud is unproven.
True.
And while there is no evidence, no evidence,
no evidence, there's so much evidence.
You saw what happened in Georgia the other
day.
They found 35000 votes.
Then they deleted in Georgia over 100000 votes.
I said, because they were so bad voters.
I said, why didn't you try doing it before?
Speaker 1: The voters were bad.
So they deleted vote.
I mean, this is this barely is English.
Speaker 3: Let's play this much.
Why didn't you do it before the election?
There's bad things going on in this country.
Speaker 1: So continuing to spread this absolute
nonsense.
Trump then moved into attacking his own former
attorney general, Bill Barr.
He's actually attacked Bill Barr a number
of times now, including because Barr didn't
do enough to take the election and he didn't
go after Democrats enough.
And very casually in this segment, Trump also
misstates what Brett Kavanaugh was even accused
of.
I mean, just it's all lies all the way down
to
Speaker 3: this because I didn't want to.
But I will.
I'm very disappointed that Bill Barr was unable
to hold anyone accountable.
Right.
For the countless abuses of power by the Democrats.
Speaker 1: The Justice Department wasn't operating
at the direction of Trump.
Translated is what that means.
Speaker 3: He didn't hold the corrupt officials
who spied on our campaign.
Remember I said this spying on our campaign.
Speaker 1: And that's, of course, another
lie that Trump's been repeating for a long
time.
Speaker 3: But that was like a lightning rod
went off.
Not the authors of the phony dossier.
They weren't held responsible, not the women.
Who slandered and lied and defamed Brett Kavanaugh.
They said Brett Kavanaugh, he had an affair.
They didn't go after them.
They lied so badly.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, Brett Kavanaugh
was not accused of having an affair.
He was accused of sexual assault and rape.
And so even misstating what it was there,
this is also another funny thing.
Check out what Donald Trump claims Joe Biden
has done in his short time in office.
So far,
Speaker 3: in a matter of mere months, Joe
Biden has brought our country to the brink
of ruin, a man
Speaker 1: who could possibly believe that.
And the answer is the people at CPAC.
And later, we're actually going to be looking
at some of the interviews because remember,
if people don't believe this trash, Trump's
in an empty room yelling at the wall.
The fact that the room is full with people
who believe it is as much a part of the problem
or even a bigger problem than the fact that
Trump exists, then Trump actually telling
the truth here.
I don't even fully get this, but Trump says
being impeached twice made him even worse.
I don't know what he means, but I think he's
actually telling the truth here.
Speaker 3: I understand that I didn't become
different.
I got impeached twice
Unidentified: and I became worse.
Speaker 3: I became worse.
Speaker 1: OK. Trump saying impeachment made
him even worse and that I actually do agree
with, that's very true, almost beyond parody.
They're going back to the migrant caravans
at any time that it's convenient.
It's migrant caravans.
Thanks to Democrats.
It's like infrastructure week.
It's like clockwork with these guys.
Speaker 3: We shut down the migrant caravans.
You haven't seen those caravans.
You get ready because they're coming up, right?
They're back and watching them come through
in those caravans.
You have some deadly people.
Speaker 1: We you know, I have to tell you,
I think Trump's disgusting.
But if Trump if someone went to him and actually,
you know, convinced him, as he likes to say,
they go to him and they say, sure, sure, exactly.
And they go, sir, just promote the vaccine.
Just go out there and promote the vaccine.
And if Trump went out there and said, guys,
listen, you know how we cheer because I made
the vaccines.
This is the lie.
He tells his supporters.
The vaccine I made, it's great for you.
Every single one of my patriotic supporters
get the patriotic vaccine.
I got it in January.
I would act.
My respect for Trump would go from zero to
one or two percent, that it would dramatically
increase my respect for the guy if he took
these opportunities.
And instead of talking about migrant caravans,
just straight up said, get yourselves vaccinated.
He's not doing it.
Instead, he's back on the cognitive test.
Speaker 3: Makes it very easy for Democrats
to cheat and to win elections.
You don't have too many of them in Texas,
Eluay.
Don't Ronnie, do we have a great dog running?
My doctor, yeah.
Became a congressman.
Right.
And the only 22 people, 22 people, he was
crazy.
I said, how about if I take a cognitive test?
He said, well, you can do it, sir, but if
you do, you know, it'll be public.
I said, what's wrong with that?
He said, Well, if you don't do well, sir,
it's not going to be pretty, sir.
I said, is it hard?
He said after the first five questions, it
gets very hard.
Speaker 1: Now, we've already debunked that
the test is not difficult.
Speaker 3: I said, let's take a shot at it.
And we did it and we aced it.
Right.
Speaker 1: IEI again.
Crowd cheering that Trump didn't fail a test
for serious advanced dementia.
That's not an applause line.
Speaker 3: And one of the doctors said he's
never seen anybody that age.
And some of those are
Speaker 1: no one's ace this test before you
have the littlest amount of dementia of anyone
we've ever looked at.
Speaker 3: Missions are not easy.
I will tell you that.
Tough stuff.
How do you think Joe would do on a cognitive
function?
Speaker 1: All right.
So anyway, there's Trump back on the cognitive
test.
He's still talking about Hillary Clinton,
by the way.
And when he does, the crowd predictably starts
chanting, lock her up, lock up there for law
and order and due process.
They say lock up people not even charged with
crime.
Speaker 3: Crooked Hillary Clinton, who, by
the way, is the most angry person in the United
States today.
She's gone away.
You know why?
She said, why the hell didn't you do that
for me in 2016?
I it there are more people than her.
Speaker 1: So going with the lock her up stuff.
Trump here saying the quiet part out loud
about polling.
This is funny because we knew this.
What was it was what he was doing.
And he's saying it to his supporters.
Speaker 3: The way you have a poll coming
out, unfortunately, I want to know what it
is.
They you know, they do that straw poll right
now.
If it's bad.
I just so I say it, it's fake, right?
If it's good, I say that's the most accurate
poll perhaps ever
Speaker 1: that we knew that's what he was
doing.
And yet his supporters laugh.
But he's telling you the truth, guys.
That's the truth about Trump's view on polling.
And then lastly, capping the speech with more
lies about the election.
And this will be a big piece of 2022 and 2024.
Speaker 3: We will never give up our search
for truth and justice for what happened in
the corrupt presidential election of 2020,
because without that truth, we cannot have
an honest election.
Speaker 1: And all that happened is he lost
money.
Speaker 3: Twenty two or twenty twenty four
no matter what they wanted to.
And our country will soon stand proudly for
free and strong and proper elections.
Now, of course,
Speaker 1: we mostly have them already.
Aside from some irregularities, the real election
fraud is the voter suppression that takes
place.
So a completely deranged speech will look
at some interviews with attendees.
We will look at the straw poll.
We're going to look at everything today, as
well as some other things.
We are now gearing up for the 16th anniversary
of The David Pakman Show on August 16th.
It will be the 16th anniversary of the show.
And we are going to be doing a membership
blowout, the likes of which no doctors have
ever even heard.
Just get on my newsletter at David Pakman
Dotcom.
And then on August 16th, you will get something
very special in your email and a great opportunity
to get a heavily, heavily discounted membership.
Let me know your thoughts about the Trump
speech.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we'll be right back.
Remember that the best way to support our
work is to get a membership at Join Pakman
dot com, I encourage you to
do it.
Why not today?
Today is as great a day as any